let's descend into the mouth of hell
shall we
[Applause]
these sessions are mandatory for all
staff sister anne
my mother struggled with depression
annie annie honey can i come in
but even as a child i knew it was danny
open the door please
more
[Music]
my mother talked about hearing that
voice inside
she said the voice didn't really want
her
it wanted me
the citadel has fallen black smoke blots
out the sun because as some of you may
already know we have a female student in
the class only as an observer so
let's descend into the mouth of hell
shall we
there are more possessions reported
today than at any other time in history
so we must fight for every soul
defend us in battle against the spirits
of wickedness
i believe the demon that is tormenting
natalie and the demon that possessed my
mother are one in the same
i'd like to teach sister just enough to
protect herself and others
this relationship she has
it's personal
we've been waiting for you
your mother has a pretty voice
be careful
once you know the devil
the devil knows you
[Music]
you